okay so first of all I would like to
thnkx or from research to give me once
again the opportunity to talk at the
technology conference and what I would
like to present to you today concern
several experiments we are doing in our
robotics labs so i'm working in is quite
small we're around 10 people's quite
small robotic labs insufficiency
policies south of france and so i would
like to show you some of the experiments
who are doing and how we use word from
language in this experiment and also to
discuss or we would you would like to
use more the world from language in
those experiments okay so one of major
center of interest was a few years ago
para para and robots and we we were
involved in the design and development
on civil robots so parallel robots you
can see what we talked about how we said
its spiral robots when the end effector
is linked to the fixed base through
civil kinematic kinematical loops and
the opposite is Syria robots when there
is only one community kinematical chain
between the end effector and the base so
we have several example we have
developed or design this one one here
you can see another one which is used as
this one we do not have developed by
yourself but we are using it for a walk
simulator but to move the carpet that's
when we have been involved so it's now
administrator robot from working tools
in digital tools but we have been
involved a lot in the in the conception
of these robots and maybe a last an
example of a big one who have been
involved so
at the opposite an example on a very
small one we have developed and this
this one is has been designed for I
don't know the name anyway inside
prospection of the body now so it's it's
really really small and on the end
effector you can put a very small knife
and then of the surgery can operate
through this small robots so I will when
we are working with such manipulator we
have a lot of equations to solve right
of equation too bright so I won't
developed lot of equation I just won't
give you a flower of that and that the
main the first reason why we are using
computer algebra system and when you are
we are using warframe language is for
the symbolic computation and computer
algebra features we have in so here of
course we are working in 3d
three-dimensional with three-dimensional
robots but for this example I prefer to
do something with a two-dimensional so
what is simple with such a robot this
one is cereal the base is blue and the
end effector is supposed to be the small
red row so what is quite simple is if
you give the configuration I mean if you
give the command you sent to the motor
at each and you give the angle of each
rotation it's quite easy to find the
position so you can see position is
computed directly what is a little bit
more complicated is the inverse inverse
computation because in disguise
you have to solve any question in the
first case there is nothing to solve
just equation 2 developed and its
explicit in this case you have to solve
and you have eventually several results
so when you are controlling the robots
such things cool happens and when you
want to avoid such a thing you have to
look at it very very precisely and
that's a good reason to use symbolic
methods because when you are using
numerical methods you don't know
precisely which which solution we will
we will get so you can follow a solution
and then have a jump without really
knowing that ok that's why we try to
push the symbolic computation as far as
possible but that was quite simple
because it was Syria robots if we work
with para robots it is much more
complicated now with para robots it is
the opposite what is easy easy in verse
1 and what is difficult is a direct one
now if you have the position in the
orientation of the end effector here's
the end effector is a small red triangle
and the fixed based as a three blue
rectangle it's quite easy to compute the
length of the legs that's linked the two
platforms okay and if you want to do the
opposite the direct model it's much more
complicated so as British or in a
previous in the previous talk I just put
a small device to guess the result and
from the gas try to get the solution so
we can put it here
turn a little bit anyway it's a way to
demonstrate that is very cool to have on
the top of a symbolic computation system
to have such manipulation and graphics
possibility because and to have
everything together and that's only in
the world foreign language okay it do
not compute the mother is just a way to
approximate the solution as you can see
and if you if we want to compute it I
told you it's more complicated so in
this case we are just planner so we just
have to solve some circle equation but
complexity grow very very quickly so
let's fix some notation and I develop
some calc computation know what just
what i want to show you sir so I i'm
using the same method than the one I
have done by n that means I try to
eliminate as much as possible all
variables except the younger years
younger appears as t.t which is modulo
change of variables is related to the
cosine and the sine of the of the
orientation of the platform so i first
tried to solve to get polynomial
equation in these tees that give me the
orientation and once i have the
orientation i can compute the ex and ey
so what is important here is this number
it's 14,600 terms so that means that is
quite big polynomial and that it will be
quite difficult to solve and we are in
the case in the two-dimensional case we
are only interested for the experiment
in the six dimensional case solving here
direct model of cetera robot has been
has been made for the first time I think
symbolically around as in 1990 between
1985
and it has been made with a lot of grub
no basis computation and the result
method is a little bit similar to that
or a lot of elimination and then to find
at the end only one polynomials and each
root of the polynomial will produce a
solution so maximum the size of the
degree of the polynomial is 40 so that
means we can have 40 solution and
fortunately usually we do not have 40
real solution only we have only a few
solution but we can have 40 so that's
means that first we need to have good
tools to do symbolic computation and
also we need to have good tools to do
numerical evaluation of this computation
but what we are interested in is to get
numerical result and with such I degree
the computation can be very unstable so
we have to perform satisfy computation
either increasing the increasing the
precision or using interval methods and
interval analysis so we did boss and we
are doing both and we are doing boss
with has evolved from language because
does functionality are available in
server from language more recently we
have been interested to cover drivin
cable driven by robots because once
solution of the mother has been has been
found in the NCATS in the 90s okay the
researcher wanted to find another game
to play with and so it could be the same
but it's even more complicated for
tourism the first reason is that on a
cable you cannot push you can just pull
yeah thank you and so you need to have
more cable to ensure that you can move
in all direction so maybe I can move
little bit
so I could you can see all the cable are
attached to the cube so it's quite it's
a quite common configuration and by
changing the length of the cable you
will move the cube and you will get hey
you will get it to move in the six with
six degree-of-freedom of course with
small courses do you mainly to cable
intersection but you have six
degree-of-freedom provided you have at
least seven cables and the second reason
why it's it's difficult to it's much
more difficult to compute it's because
you cannot use just geometric or
kinematical kinematical model you need
to take in account the the force exist
inside the keyboard because you need to
know when a k-bar is no longer straight
yeah thank you and so it's important
because at this time as something some
dimension changes and computation change
so you need to use the statical
dynamical model so that's why we are we
need the tool which is good not only for
symbolic computation but also for
numerical computation because we have no
up today to get a symbolic result with
this geometrical and statical model okay
so i will show you a couple of
experiment we have done so we have yeah
we first have a risk ukraine so we have
six devices like this one with with 1k
bar and we put one of the top of several
of the top of the of the battlements and
the idea was to control this is part of
plane as something to rescue people
mainly and maybe
so there is a few of the end summaries
with five five of the six devices the
sixth one is a little bit below on the
on the parking lot there and with the
help of numerical computation of the
model and control we can almost safely
move the guy who lies on the platform
and we can also use these things to try
to escape guy or remove some object
without taking in a risk so that whether
one of the experiment we have done and
we also have a series of smaller robots
which name is Maya net because it's it's
moved by cable so this one is the first
is the first one it is a cuboid of let's
say 2 x 1.5 meter maybe 2.5 x 1.5 and we
have eight engines on this picture only
four cables are in effect but it is
linear engine you see one here and we
have we have eight linear engine on
these robots okay another example is an
a crane to move people in the room for
example for disabled people or
tetraplegic people now this one there
are still for cable and in this case we
do not have to to control rotation so
it's for keyboards completely
inauthentic cable for keyboard attached
at the same at the same point and so the
last one it is a robot's we have
installed in a virtual reality rule so
we have a war of screen and right now we
have done just very small experiment but
we would like to experiment the mixing
of virtual reality
and this kind of this kind of technology
of robotics technology okay so that's it
was the main the main part of what week
once we call robots usually but
Thursday's robots are much more
complicated and recurrent robots
whatever kind of complex system which
can sense the environment and take some
decision and react on its environment so
the lab probably shift from
progressively as shift two assistants
robotics and we are dealing with our
devices and connected devices and the
program begin to be different we are not
that much interested in the mechanical
or geometrical models we're much more
interesting in communication in that
acquisition and data analysis modeling
control and so on so a few example ok
one more crane it has been designed for
the European robotics weeks the idea was
is supposed to be a nuclear plant with
something burning and we have to put
this moving stuff on in the red box and
it was supposed to be a game during this
six weeks so we have to control this
device from from a website any kind of
website so at this time we're not not
enough access to the warm language sure
we have met that with another language
for foreign dealing with devices and
connected device which name is up but I
would like to set to set up again this
experiment with the world from language
as soon at it will be possible so what I
have done with the world foreign
language is some kind of
simulation and you can move the end
effector as you want and then you can
see what you can see here as a command
computed by the buds model and if you
check that then you send these comments
to the device the device there are
fidget it's not arduino equipped so it's
fidget fidget are a little bit like
arduino series but it is made by sun
microsystems and i would love a word
from to consider that using this device
in the program and with this to attack
the speech yet we are using a gel ink
and the Java API so that's what is done
and we would like to implement some
raspberry pi based solution but the test
we have made with raspberry pi is that
it's quite loud especially if you want
to do some graphics so i will have no
problem to compute two computers the
modern and to send to send the other and
to make the control the control loop but
I'm afraid I won't be able to make to
have this interface working on the
Raspberry Pi okay we also did some
calibration and autocare abortions or
imaginalis with the help of foreign
language what else so we are working
with more letters and we did some some
experiments as this one was a medical
experiment we wanted to enhance the
usual medical tests for work and this
test is you usually at least in France
is usually your your doctor is just
controlling how much time you need to go
there and come back and the only a
measurable quantity is it's a time and
with such a radar which is equipped with
sensor on
the wheels and 3x accelerometers with
such later we can have a good idea of
what is the trajectory so we use were
from language to once we have got the
result we've got the result with all the
other devices but when we have got the
result we use of run from language to
analyze devices and that's a result of
one experience we can G and trajectory
and that the result we add with several
people's working and yeah we had to set
of people and one set was quite all
people and set the result are in blue
and the other set is in red it was quite
young people so we can see from from
here that there is something to analyze
there and we are currently working and
and that so with this later which is a
little bit more big and more equipped so
this one as motorists and brake on the
wheels and also said that solar panel to
get the 4g energy and there is a pc and
bark and several on accelerometers your
gps and so on so with this with this one
we walk through the campus and we have
fine the place is different just tipnis
of the rod stiffed you know stiffness
stiffness of the of the rod and anyway
now it's better I show you so that's
that the campus and so the blue blue
green line as a place where you can
easily walk it's quite flat blue line it
is a little bit like that and the red
line it's not possible to to go with a
wheelchair for example and also each of
the K each of the key be it's the place
where the site the sidewalk is doing
like that so you can go with wheelchair
now all that stuff have been
I've been done with the help of this
radar and we use were from language to
get the result and to analyze the result
I mean especially change the format of
the result to be able to export it to
openstreetmap project okay one more
example so it's small robots aside it's
a toy we use for when when we can Jesse
program for certain to 14 years old
students and the idea is to make those
people understand all the program which
are behind using a using a robot control
calibration and modeling and so on and
of course the robots usually come with a
manual commands and we change that with
the fidgets with a fidget ball so they
also have to understand the board and
how it works and we control all that
things with a word from language program
so i will show you what kind of things
yeah we have its bit bigger big
okay so that's the kind of thing I asked
them to home to build yeah to draw this
simulation and what we are doing with
the world from language on top of this
model in to do a high level tasks to try
to understand what all the higher level
tests can be divided into low level task
and also we realize the frigid
connection and we can connect all the
computer to the tooth to the robots what
is not yet done is to connect this kind
of interface just moving the interface
and then the robot is moving it's not
yet done but I think I could do that
soon okay so the last exemplar we change
the legs of a bed we replace the legs by
force sensors and those force sensor is
connected to a raspberry pi so the
Raspberry Pi is connecting the data of
the four legs of the bed and we have
some records for one night of sleeping
of course and so from from this from
this data which we try to guess what are
the phases of sleeping and we are
experimenting with with doctors we are
experimenting or we can also can use
that to replace the heavy process of
experimenting am use your mount of of
sleep which is something very heavy you
have to put EJ and anything like that ok
so and we also would like to see how it
is connected to the small devices we
could offer for example the like things
you put there also the Fitbit or things
like that activity trackers and that
gives also result concerning the or you
sleep so what we got is yeah that's mass
versus a time here we have the math
center position and we try to guess the
motion of the people inside the bed and
after some analysis we have shown some
result on the slip faces and there is
this so each color means one of the one
of the sensor and you can see that we
have concurred also of the result we are
still working on this on this tree okay
I think it's time to conclude them so
the reason why I like foreign languages
because it's doing all those things and
everything is really integrated I mean
it is always the same the same ideas
same way of processing whatever you are
processing your processing images sounds
polynomials numbers